so left Parnas left Parnas is the
indicted henchmen of trumps lawyer rudy
giuliani he has already said I will
testify under oath that Devin Nunez was
flying to Europe and trying to push
Ukrainian officials to find or to claim
to have dirt on Biden left Parnas has
now reportedly delivered recordings of
Trump and Giuliani to the House
Intelligence Committee that's running
the impeachment hearings depending on
what is on those recordings this may be
the blockbuster so far of this entire
story these are audio and video
recordings as well as photographs and
these include Donald Trump and Rudy
Giuliani we don't yet know what is on
the recordings but what is increasingly
clear is that left Parnas is not the
type of guy to mess with especially
after he has also implicated Devon Nunez
personally in being part of the
round-the-world trips seeking dirt on
Joe Biden on taxpayer dollars by the way
as we already discussed really it seems
that people like love harness and Igor
Fuhrman are the types of people it's
best not to associate with at all
because they might be helping rudy
giuliani do his stuff for Donald Trump
at first but these are not dumb people
and they were collecting recordings and
at least as far as left Parnas goes Egor
Froman has actually not cooperated at
all left arnis seems ready to spill the
beans and has already turned over audio
visual recordings involving Donald Trump
and Rudy Giuliani I think it was James
Comey that said oh lordy there are tapes
this is potentially huge and this feels
again like history repeating itself
going back to Nixon in the 1970s where a
whole bunch of stuff happened a whole
bunch of allegations and assertions were
made and then at some point into the
scandal it was learned there are
recordings and the recordings of course
are very very damaging in many of these
cases now I got an email yesterday over
the weekend saying David don't you think
that Russians have the Oval Office
bugged at this point Trump had that
Russian spy recruiter Sergey kis lyac in
the Oval Office we have to believe
Donald Trump is under surveillance by
the Russians
don't we I don't know the answer nothing
would surprise me at this point but as
far as these tapes go if Trump is on the
tapes we can only assume it's not good
for him because consider how self
incriminating Donald Trump is in public
right Donald Trump doesn't even have the
sense or the ability to avoid
self-incrimination in public later I'll
get to his latest Fox News interview
which is which is a doozy and he does a
lot of self-incrimination if you
understand how useless and clueless
Trump is when it comes to not self
incriminating when he knows that he's in
public imagine what this guy says in
private and people who are behind the
scenes who were behind the scenes on his
reality show The Apprentice have talked
about this and I'm not even talking
about the likely use of racial slurs
which Trump is accused of behind the
scenes at The Apprentice more likely the
tapes could be of Trump and
conversations which clearly indicate he
knows people he has since claimed not to
know there could be tapes of Trump using
language that makes it obvious that he
specifically wanted a quid pro quo
bribery extortion whatever the tapes
could be anything and I can't imagine
that they are exculpatory in nature so
we'll we will see what comes of these
tapes the House of Representatives
Intelligence Committee reportedly just
working through the tapes right now my
prediction is number one this is not
going to be a particularly good week for
Devon Nunez and if anything the
Thanksgiving holiday will help them to
take attention away from this absolutely
disastrous news and it's also important
to remember just as a general thing when
we are looking at this issue of tapes
and recordings and everything else Trump
thinks that the things he says in
private are exculpatory so for example
last week when Gordon Sunland testified
on a phone call Donald Trump said I
don't want a quid pro quo and then
Donald Trump heard that and said hey
that sounds great that makes me sound
innocent and he came out and with the
helicopter weighed blades whirring he
said here's what I told Sunland on the
phone I don't want a quid pro quo and
then any common-sense thinker would
wait a second there's no quid pro quo
why are you calling your ambassador and
saying I definitely don't want a quid
pro quo this is like the example I gave
last week I'll cop I call my girlfriend
and tell her hey pick up a few things at
the grocery store and listen don't
shoplift yeah I don't want you
shoplifting I don't want you stealing
this stuff unless there was reason to
think that that would happen
you wouldn't even bring that up and of
course we know that now the timing of
Donald Trump's saying this to Gordon
Sunland was because he already knew that
allegations of quid pro quo were growing
it doesn't help his case whatsoever he
doesn't even realize it and after the
break were actually going to get to
video which once again this is just a
gong show bizarre interview on Fox News
where I believe Trump thinks he is
making himself look innocent and he has
actually completely self incriminated
that's coming up later make sure that
you are signed up on the David Pakman
show newsletter Black Friday this Friday
we will have an email blast going out
with an amazing membership discount if
you've been sort of thinking about
becoming a david pakman show member and
supporting independent media this Friday
will be a good day to do it we'll have
an email going out in the early
afternoon with a coupon code so be
notified of that coupon code simply get
on our newsletter at david pakman.com
let me know what you think about the
tapes on Twitter at Dee Pakman today's
program brought to you in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinkie's
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink as'
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listen to on bling cos
they're constantly adding new books to
the Platt
you will never run out of fascinating
and critically acclaimed books to enjoy
and our audience can get a seven day
free trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you'd like
it you can continue enjoying thousands
of condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is
t-dot-com /p a que mas